[Musica]
come vi sentite stasera fisicamente
emotivamente
che sensazioni provate non verbalizzate
le ma come dire portatele a maggior
consapevolezza e se avete un pezzo di
carta con due parole scrivetele nulla di
più di questo
[Musica]
come vi sentite rispetto a un minuto fa
e dico un minuto fa niente qualcosa bene
rilassati tranquilli
bambino bambino che bello ancora
curiosity sapete che la musica è la cosa
più consumata al mondo
accompagno molto spesso il nostro fare
quotidiano ci tende degli agguati negli
ascensori dal dentista nei bar nei
ristoranti
eppure una scarsa percentuale di persone
ascolta la musica classica insieme e dal
vivo intanto ci intendiamo brevemente su
che cos'è la musica classica è
importante per questo breve percorso la
musica classica e la musica esatta è la
musica che è stata scritta dall'autore
esattamente nel modo in cui egli vuole
che sia eseguita con quelle note con
quelle concatenazioni armoniche con
quell'andamento questa musica
soprattutto nei suoi grandi capolavori
di cui avete sentito un piccolo assaggio
adesso ha una tale vitalità una tale
massa critica che bussa alle porte della
memoria offrendoci veramente chiavi
formidabili di interpretazioni di noi
stessi
noi siamo infatti noi stessi costituiti
di ciò che sono stati i nostri avi non
siamo fatti noi gli elementi primari
essa trascina con sé in sensazioni che
accomunano gli esseri umani attraverso i
secoli che non porti con sé il senso di
eternità
incarnando il canone della bellezza
essa ci fa provare sensazioni tante
volte così profonde e così complesse che
noi non abbiamo un nome per definire la
musica fa questa cosa meravigliosa da un
nome a queste sensazioni un nome che non
è fatto di parole ma è fatto di note
dunque per tuffarci in questa avventura
non occorre tanto di sapere di teorie
musicali di diesis o di bemolle basta
farne esperienza
il metalinguaggio che la musica poiché
la musica un linguaggio è una metafora
in se stessa metafora oporto al di là
provvederà a un nome per queste emozioni
un nome che non è logos parola ma è
aisthesis senso questa musica è
sovrabbondante di senso nella sua
complessità che ha una parvenza di
naturalezza
non siamo noi stessi gli umani esseri
complessi con una parvenza di
naturalezza non lo è il mondo non lo è
l'universo
ma torniamo le vostre sensazioni bambino
serenità
tutte bellissime tutte vere tutte
diverse
benché generate da un'unica fonte anche
questa è una cosa meravigliosa della
musica
provate a rimanere dove esse mi
risuonano questa musica tante volte
bussa alla nostra porta senza essere
invitata
conosciamo tutti noi questi ingressi non
richiesti essa penetra in noi e fa parte
di noi
o forse siamo noi che facciamo parte di
essa ma chi è l'ospite a bella parola
nella nostra bella lingua che significa
sia colui che ospita che colui che viene
ospitato il patto tra i due è talmente
profondo e sacro che i due ruoli si
confondono significano la stessa parola
ma attenzione l'ospite va accolto
poiché come dice un li greci potrebbe
essere zeus in persona e questo
movimento che fa l'ospite di andare
avanti e indietro di entrare così come
la musica come le note saltano da una
all'altra si collegano in questo
movimento continuo che strano che in
tante lingue del mondo suonare si dica
to play su e sugar gratis pillan e
questo movimento ci dice tanto di come
ci sentiamo molto
di quanto lo possano dire milioni di
parole
questo movimento inoltre ci collega con
la sensazione della finitezza della
nostra esistenza con il battito del
nostro cuore ritmo del nostro respiro e
forte rimando il mito delle sirene disse
è atteso dalle sirene le sirene lotte
non attendo labile parlato real
corazzato di grammatica e di logica che
per sentire il loro canto però si deve
legare al palo della nave i suoi amici
farsi sordi
altrimenti sarebbero inevitabilmente
trascinati nel sonno della ragione ma
noi questo ospite lo vogliamo accogliere
abbiamo la possibilità di fare questo
silenzio per accogliere questo ospite
abbiamo la volontà soprattutto di
abitare le sensazioni che esso risveglia
in noi
in una società contemporanea che ha
perduto un pochettino il senso del
silenzio dell'armonia del ritmo delle
stagioni del fitto e poi perché questa
musica scortava ascoltarle insieme
abbiamo tanti strumenti tecnologici per
ascoltarla quando vogliamo come vogliamo
per accendere spegnere a nostro
piacimento
però il rito collettivo di ascoltare
insieme presuppone una certa qual
cortesia una certa qual e
predisposizione all'ingresso dell'ospite
e forse in questo atto dell'ascoltare
forse si forma questo una c'era un certo
effetto di risonanze un effetto eco tra
coloro che ascoltano dato proprio da
questa con un e predisposizione
all'accoglienza dell'ospite
e forse questa musica e terna che nasce
rimane nei secoli che non abbia lei
stessa un senso civico di comunità
niente come la musica dice il grande
comparatista di orly steiner ci fa
sentire come monadi perseguitate del
desiderio di comunione in fondo che
cos'è questa bella grande invenzione di
greci il teatro è un buco vuoto dove si
rappresenta una vita aumentata dove si
squaderna una poetica del vero dove
avviene una finzione come dice
aristotele che più vera e universale
della storia
due grandi doni stanno nel grembo della
nostra cara e vecchia europa il teatro
un buco vuoto dentro quale avviene una
vita aumentata e la musica scritta la
musica esatta la musica che si tramanda
la musica e terna vi lascio con una
piccola considerazione è un piccolo
esperimento tra di noi
una teoria affascinante secondo me
fonologica dice che la musica nacque dal
grido di chiamata seguito da al grido di
risposta
ora non possiamo fare questo esperimento
ancestrale proprio tra di noi proviamo a
farlo
tra di noi vediamo chi c'è qui davanti
lei signora nella seconda fila come si
chiama laura il signore a fianco
giovanni carissima laura se lei dovesse
prendere l'attenzione di giovanni fosse
così vicina come adesso senza usare
mezzi tecnologici ma solo con le sue
risorse umane diciamo così come farebbe
per chiamare il suo nome
provi giovanni ma se giovanni per caso
invece di essere lì vicino a lei non
fosse dietro le quinte di questo teatro
oppure nel foyer oppure nell'ultimo
palco dell'ultimo ordine di questo
bellissimo teatro ricordi
cielo all'italiana come farebbe per
chiamarlo come il grido trapassa nel
canto senza soluzione di continuità da
questo bisogno di contatto da questo
bisogno di comunione nacque la musica è
musica fu
[Applauso]